Hey, Thoughty2 here!
Charles Blondin crossed Niagara Falls several times, on a 1000 foot tight rope.
Blindfolded, in a sack, on stilts, carrying a man on his back and cooking an omelette in the middle.
Welcome to RIF!
The buttons on women's shirts are the opposite side to men's shirts.
Because in the Victorian era, upper class women were dressed by their servants.
And it was easier for another person to button up the shirt if the buttons were placed on the left side.
Hitler's home phone number was listed in 'Who's Who'
Until 1945!
It was 'Berlin 11 6191'
At least 99% of all the species that have ever existed have left no trace in the fossil record.
When snakes are born with 2 heads..
They fight each other for food!
The amount of force you use when you bite into a carrot is the exact same amount required to bite your little finger off.
Emissions from car exhausts are responsible for more deaths...
every year...
than road accidents.
Camels chew in a figure of 8 pattern.
1 in every 4 Americans has appeared on television at least once in their life
In ancient Rome, when a man testified in court...
He would swear on his testicles.
What is called a 'French kiss' in the English speaking world.
Is known as an 'English kiss' in the French speaking world.
On average, Blondes have more hair than people with dark colored hair.
Ancient Egyptians shaved off their eyebrows to mourn the death of their cats.
In the Arctic, the sun sometimes appears to be square.
A female ferret will die if it goes into heat...
but cannot find a mate.
The original story from 'Tales of 1001 Arabian nights'...
Begins...
'Aladdin was a little Chinese boy'
Thanks for the view!
Subscribe for more Thoughty2!